we've started in this book with
understanding your strengths and
weaknesses understanding your passions
trying to filter out conventional wisdom
and peer pressure so you can actually
focus on who you are but those will only
get you so far you have to take one big
additional step which is you have to
understand yourself further and what I
mean by that is you need to understand
your story and your life what I ask
people to do is first of all write down
the facts of their life now everybody
can do that right I was born certain
place my parents did the following
things I grew up went to high school
brothers and sisters and just write out
the facts second step four is is I point
out to people ask them to think about
the narrative that they attach to that
story everyone whether they realize or
not puts a spin a narrative on their
life story and for most of us we are
taught through most of our life to put
what I'd call the success narrative on
our life story how we triumph persevered
what we learned it all worked out okay
it had a happy ending it may be about
adversity and how I how I had setbacks
but it usually is a story about me
prevailing there's a third story then
and that I would call your failure
narrative it is a story usually based on
traumas in your life setbacks in your
life the punchline to that story is
usually in your head I'm not good enough
I can't do something I'm afraid this is
not such a happy story and it seldom is
one that you tell but it's there in your
head whether you are aware of it or not
and what I try to do with people is get
them to write down their own failure
narrative and I'm not trying to do that
to get them to stop having a failure
narrative because I won't be able to do
that
work but to get people to be aware of it
because normally if you're in a job or
in a career and you're struggling that
struggle is more often than not not just
connected to your skills it's more
likely connected to your doubt about
yourself your insecurities which
normally relates to it something that
happened in your life the only reason to
do this is not because I'm trying to be
a psychoanalyst it's to figure out why
you do what you do my purpose is to get
you started on a path with a number of
exercises you can do in action steps so
you start understanding yourself better
it is essential part of reaching your
potential and doing what you're really
meant to do